we just got a bunch of Donald Trump's
tax filings and they're stunning
and these are not look full I think
before we go any further I should remind
you these are not the tax returns these
are not like the much-coveted recent
personal tax returns that Congress is
trying to get from the Treasury
these are filings from 1985 to 1994 for
Donald Trump but what they reveal is
absolutely fascinating you'll remember
that Donald Trump ran on being a great
business person and a deal maker and in
fact if you take that away if you
question Donald Trump's credentials as a
great business person and a deal maker
the guy has no credentials of any kind
it's sort of scary whether being a good
deal maker makes you a good president is
an open question but if you take that
pseudo credential away there's nothing
there at all but then you might remember
that during the 2016 campaign people
started rightly bringing up wait wait a
second hold on your businesses have
filed for bankruptcy many times are you
actually the great business person you
claim to be and Trump's explanation at
the time was that's because I was using
bankruptcy as a strategic tool to my
advantage it wasn't because my
businesses were failing businesses it
wasn't that I made bad deals when my
business is declared bankruptcy I was
intelligently taking advantage of
bankruptcy protection there is a
fantastic new report in The New York
Times which tells us that that's very
very much untrue it looked at Donald
Trump's 1040 which is the the primary
federal tax form from 1985 to 1994 and
it is painting a very different picture
of Trump than genius businessman which
is what he has been touting for years
now over the 10-year period that the New
York Times reviewed Donald Trump
reported 1.17 billion dollars in losses
this was not common with high net worth
taxpayers at the time who would be
taking strategic losses for in order to
gain tax advantages Trump's losses were
outliers at the time they were
extraordinarily big and they were
genuine business losses these were not
straight
hyk write downs or write offs or use of
sophisticated accounting measures and in
fact you know how Trump said that
finding ways to avoid paying taxes would
make him smart
there was nothing smart about this Trump
avoided federal income taxes for eight
of the ten years that were reviewed not
because of tricky or sophisticated
accounting maneuvers he straight up lost
a ton of money and therefore avoided
paying taxes during eight of the ten
years that the New York Times reviewed
and more importantly Donald Trump's
staff have been continuing to tell
massive and demonstrably false lies
about all of this the New York Times was
working on this story so they went to
Donald Trump's team to get a comment
about what they had uncovered and a
senior official said to them quote the
president got massive depreciation and
tax shelter because of large-scale
construction and subsidized developments
that is why the president has always
scoffed at the tax system and said you
need to change the tax laws you can make
a large income and not have to pay a
large amount of taxes this is just not
true ok this again makes it sound like
tax sheltering
and subsidies and depreciation losses
created on paper losses for Trump which
allowed him to really intelligently
avoid taxes during eight of those 10
years those are flat-out lies and in
fact a lawyer for Donald Trump put out a
statement saying that what the New York
Times is claiming about Trump is quote
demonstrably false but when that lawyer
was asked well what's an example of
something that's demonstrably false if
it's demonstrably false demonstrate that
it's false and Trump's lawyer was unable
to actually cite a single specific claim
that is demonstrably false so what we've
learned here is that Donald Trump's tax
avoidance during these specific years
was not this enlightened proactive tax
strategy it was indicative of an
unstable and poorly run business that
was losing actual money period
now with Trump there's always usually
lurking in the background a dose of
hypocrisy that we can often find if we
look at his tweets and in fact Trump
tweeted in 2012 that quote half of
Americans don't
pay income tax despite crippling
government debt as if they're bad people
well Trump was one of those people for
eight of the ten years that the New York
Times reviewed in the mid-80s and the
mid-90s and if we ever actually got
Donald Trump's more recent tax returns
my guess is we would find out that he
was also one of those people not paying
federal taxes at the same time that he
sent the tweet criticizing that quote
nearly half of Americans don't pay
income tax this morning Trump clearly
rattled by this put out a tweet actually
a to tweet word salad which read quote
real estate developers in the 1980s and
1990s more than 30 years ago were
entitled to massive write-offs and
depreciation which would if one was
actively building show losses and tax
losses in almost all cases much was
non-monetary sometimes considered tax
shelter you would get it by building or
even buying you always wanted to show
losses for tax purposes almost all real
estate developers did and often
renegotiate with banks it was sport
additionally the very old information
put out is a highly inaccurate fake news
hit job almost everything he said in
there was not true the sort of common
nature of what was revealed in Trump's
tax filings is not actually common the
idea that Donald Trump's losses were
only on paper losses for the reasons
he's citing is not true I mean none of
this is true it's certainly not fake
news and it's actually been confirmed by
looking at the tax filings of his dad
Fred Trump at the time they were
involved in a lot of the same projects
financially and everything absolutely
matches up so why do we care about this
we care about this because number one
Trump has gone crazy to prevent his more
recent tax returns from being released
and now we have proof that from has lied
about his tax history he lies and his
advisers lie about the characterization
of why he shows losses on many years and
we know that it's very very likely on
this basis that Donald Trump is just not
nearly as rich as he has claimed to be
he's an egomaniac that would upset him
if it were confirmed but maybe more
importantly people this far in the red
people who were losing this much money
are a subject to are easier to
manipulate and to take advantage of
which is exactly what many of the
investigations into Trump are looking at
Russian oligarchs laundering money
through Trump's businesses over the more
recent years the problems with sketchy
Deutsche Bank dealings Saudis using
Trump's properties to launder money
later on today I'm going to tell you
about a connection to the
second-in-command and Nicolas maduro's
regime involved in real estate purchases
from Trump Organization businesses and
lastly if you look into the detail of
this investigation
you can pick almost any number that is
in the tax filings and investigate it
and you might find something that
something sketchy like for example in 89
there was a 52 million dollar interest
payment what is that that number alone
might have an entire history behind it
which could be anything it could be
nothing or it could be more sketchy and
strange behavior we need Trump's more
recent tax returns hopefully Democrats
in the house can get them sooner than
later so that we can actually learn the
full scope of this and most Americans
want to see those tax returns every
other candidate in the last 40 years has
released their tax returns we've got to
see them and hopefully the House Ways
and Means Committee will ultimately be
able to get them what do you think is
the most notable thing about Trump's 85
to 90 for taxes I'm on Twitter let me
know at D Pakman and the show is also on
twitter at david pakman show today's
program was made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman better help
is an online service that gives you
access to your own experienced fully
licensed therapist via phone video and
text when you see a therapist in person
in their office it can take three weeks
on average before you're able to get in
for your first appointment but with
better help you're matched with a
therapist who fits your needs within
just 24 hours and you get the same
professional service and the best part
is that better help is less expensive
than seeing a therapist in person as
well plus you will have totally
unlimited access to the therapist
you can talk to them whenever you want
on your phone or computer and because
better help believes in what they do
they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an extensive vetting process
and are required to have at least three
years of experience before joining
better help so you know you're getting
someone who's fully qualified to help
you but if you don't think that your
therapist is a good fit better help lets
you switch to someone new at any time if
you've been thinking about getting
involved with therapy you should really
check out better help just click the
link underneath this video